as I was doing my daily cover
investigation into the Paycheck
protection program we quickly realized
that many small businesses were being
shut out of the first round of funding I
started looking into some of the
resources that were already out there to
try to help these small businesses and
came across better fit which serves as a
technology layer for entrepreneurs and
small businesses to help them get access
to lending this is a company we were
excited about last year when we invested
before you know anyone could have
predicted this pandemic and the
resulting recession from it the reason
we invested back then was because SMBs
are the lifeblood of the American
economy
it's a massive market about eight
hundred billion dollars in annual
origination for all this SME lending and
that lending is currently done you know
pretty inefficiently there's not a lot
of software used in that process
historically and then of course in a
crisis like this where it is vital that
we get cash money into the hands of
these small medium businesses you know
the need for something like better fit
is more important than ever as over 30
million American small businesses have
been cast into financial freefall better
fan rolled out ready relief a free
TurboTax like platform helping these
businesses secure financial stimulus
funding being a software first business
they're able to take what they were
already doing and then adapt ready
relief to solving this particular need
which is accessing these government
bailout dollars when when everything
sort of happened with Kove it became
quite clear that the same way that a
business owner is gonna need help to
really navigate the pain to work and
process to apply for you know the SBA
loans that we were doing before the
pandemic business owners were also gonna
need help with these programs that the
SBA was rolling now ready relief is
really the idea of it you know a
business owner can work with their SBA
advisor put together their paperwork or
the application package you know not
only comprehensively but but accurately
number one challenge has been that you
know I think business owners are living
in a world where day to day there's
streaming updates
around who qualifies where do I go
what's the process how long is it gonna
take in the meanwhile you know every day
that goes by is just a deepening of the
financial hardship that many of these
business owners are going through the
first round of PPP money ran out quickly
and although a second round was
authorized in late April others in small
business financing advised a faster
approach to securing a loan my concern
with folks like better finish that well
I think they have a good platform for
the normal course of stuff I think right
now the big challenge is gonna be that
you know there is so much of demand
compared to supply so there's no point
in having more transparency to be honest
you know there's not the time to shop
around this is the time to secure your
loan there are not many options for the
business owners and it don't have the
luxury of time they don't have luxury of
you know saying that okay whether I take
it or I don't take this money you know
most of these businesses will not get
any money I think the overall advice
would be to very much not plan for a
v-shaped recovery a much longer one is
is to come and you know certainly if you
do qualify for all the small business
owners please please take full advantage
of these dollars on you know whether
it's PPP or SBA a it is vital that we
get money back into the small businesses
in America and back into mainstream
because that is those are the dollars
they're gonna stay in the communities
those the dollars they're gonna get
spent and and keep this economy moving
especially while we're in this
suppressed time and then help us recover
faster
you
[Music]